welcome back on problem number 12
problem 12 if K is a positive integer
what is the least value of K for which
square root of five K over three is an
integer so this whole thing has to be an
integer if the whole thing is going to
be an integer the thing inside of the
square root has to be an integer as well
right there I can't have a frac the
square root of a fraction is never going
to be an integer so five K over three is
going to be an integer and you know we
could also immediately say that K has to
be multiple of three that's the only way
there's going to be an integer but let's
think about what type of a perfect
square this has to be this perfect
square is is going it has to be
divisible by five how do I know that
well let's just rewrite it as five times
K over three it has to be a multiple of
five and this has to be an integer right
which we just said K has to be divisible
by three because that's the only way
that this whole thing is gonna be an
integer is if K over three is an integer
so what is the smallest perfect square
that is divisible by five the smallest
perfect square that's divisible by five
because we want K to be the smallest
possible number right the smallest
possible integer so the smallest perfect
square that is a multiple of five is of
course 5 squared which is 25 so let's
set this equal to 25 so five K over
three is going to be equal to 25 I think
we could multiply both sides by 3 you
get 5 K is equal to 75 divide both sides
by 5 you get K is equal to 15 and you
can try it out put 15 in here this whole
thing becomes 25 and then the square
root becomes 5 and they're all integers
next problem ok they drew some boxes or
some shapes this one one and this one
looks something like this
it's one one and then this one looks
something like this
this is two one the figures above
represent three pieces of cardboard all
angles of the cardboard pieces are right
angles fair enough all short sides have
length one and all long sides have
length 2 which of the following figures
could have been made from only the three
pieces of cardboard without overlapping
them so let's let's draw these these
choices so choice one looks like this
comes down like this this is two this
comes down like this this goes like this
this length is three so maybe I'll try
to fit the biggest piece in let's see
what I have left over so the only place
where that big piece can fit in is right
here right that's the only place the big
piece can fit in and then I could fit in
this small piece I can put it here but
they have no space right that or that is
not enough space for this piece so one
does not work choice two choice - okay
so it has length 4 and it goes to one
like that and then it goes to then it
comes back so this is 2 - this is 1 so
where can I fit the big piece let's try
that first well they're really the only
place where I'll fit because it's 3 wide
is right here this is the only place
where the big piece will fit and then
where can I fit the small piece well
this looks like a pretty obvious place
for the small plate piece because
obviously the medium piece isn't gonna
be feeling it there and can I fit the
medium piece can this piece fit here
well sure I just have to rotate it and
how do I know that well it let me let me
show if I can visualize it if I rotate
it so that this side becomes this side
and that
this side right here becomes this side
and then I could keep going I could say
this side is this side this is actually
strangely fun this side is this side I
think you get the picture and you know
this side is this side so I think you
get the idea I just rotated it so this
one works choice 2 works let's look at
choice 3 choice 3 looks like this it's
it's also for high go out one down step
it's like a step goes down 2 then it
comes out like that it comes like that
so this is 4 1 1 2 1 so where can we fit
the big piece the big piece is 3 wide so
this is the only part that's 3 wide but
there's no place to stick the bottom
part of the big piece right the big
piece could fit like this but there's no
place to put this part so the big piece
I can't figure out a way to make the big
piece feet I don't think it can because
this is the only part that's 3 wide
right could this be three wide so the
choice 3 is also not the answer so the
answer is 2 only and that's choice C
next problem problem 14 how many
integers greater than 20 and less than
30 are each the product of exactly two
different numbers both of which are
prime okay exactly two different numbers
both of which are so let's just list out
all the numbers between 20 and 30 not
including those 2 right because greater
than 20 less than 30 so 21 22 23 24 25
26 27 28 29 21 has so should we count
one and the number as factors well no
because one is not a prime number prime
numbers or all the numbers greater than
2 greater than or equal to two that have
to the half sorry that have one and
itself as the only factors so let's see
how many factors other than 100 itself
are both different and both prime so
this has 3 and 7 and that's all I can
get out of it and these are both prime
so this works
this has 2 times 11 these are both prime
I can't think of any other two numbers
that divide into 22 so that one works 23
only has 1 times 23 one isn't prime and
I mean all of these also have that kind
of identity factor so it's not 23 24 has
2 times 12 and 6 times 4 and all of none
of those are prime so 24 doesn't work 25
has 5 times 5
both are prime but they're not different
numbers so that doesn't work 2 times 13
ghosts of 26 and that's the only factors
so that works 27 has 3 times 9 but 9 is
in prime right its composite number it's
divisible by 3 so that doesn't work
28 has 2 times 14 and 7 times 2 and so
it has multiple factors and 14 isn't
isn't prime so it doesn't work 29 has is
is prime so it doesn't have any other
different numbers 2 different numbers
that divide into that it primarily has 1
times 29 doesn't have anything else and
what isn't prime so there's 1 2 3
choices so that's D I actually think
this was a little badly worded because I
don't know you can you could you could
argue that the number itself is a factor
that is is it I guess the product of
exactly two numbers and one can't count
right right it has to be the product of
two numbers and so you can't count one
in itself because one is not a prime
number both both of the numbers that
make up the product have to be prime all
right problem number 15 problem 15 so
they drew us a triangle they tell us
that this is 7 minus X this is 7 plus X
this is 10 this is 90 degrees and they
say the figure above is a right triangle
what is the value 49 plus x squared so
let's do the Pythagorean theorem this
squared plus this squared has to equal
that squared so 7 minus X 7 minus x
squared plus 7 plus x squared is going
to equal 100 this equals 49 minus 2x
plus x squared this is equal to plus 49
plus 2
plus X squared that equals 100 this
minus 2x and this plus 2x are gonna
cancel out all right and now this is
what 49 plus 49 that's the same thing as
2 times 49 and you have x squared plus x
squared plus 2x squared I could have
multiplied this out but you'll see why I
didn't because I want to preserve that
49 in there and that equals so this was
100 it's equals 100 factor out the 2
factor out the 2 you get 2 times 49 plus
x squared is equal to 100 preserve the
49 and then divide both sides by 2 you
get 49 plus x squared is equal to 50 and
we are done
that's the answer that's choice a see in
the next video